bank of america said tuesday that it
will raise an
hourly minimum wage of its employees by
2025 to 25 bucks an hour it costs
us a few hundred million dollars a year
but it's an investment the bank ceo
brian
said it's not the first time bank of
america has raised its minimum wage for
its employees in 2017 the bank raised
its minimum wage to 15 bucks an hour
two years later the company announced it
would lift all uh
the that level to 20 bucks an hour
upcoming two years and so
did the schedule now be in uh with an
increase that impacted more than 200
000 workers last month biden signed an
executive order lifting minimum wage for
federal contractors
workers to 15 bucks an hour in early
2022 from the current level of 10.95
meanwhile other banks are also raising
wages all by not as aggressively
jp morgan chase announced 2018 that it
would increase his minimum wage from 15
bucks 20 bucks an hour for 22 000
employees
depending on their local cost of living
citigroup raises minimum wage from 15
bucks an hour to 50 bucks an hour in
2019. so
25 bucks an hour is bank of america
really raising their minimum wage to 25
bucks an hour or tom are they saying
we just want better pool of talent that
we're paying for
we're willing to pay fifty thousand
dollar an hour because fifty thousand
dollars a year because at fifty thousand
dollars here we're going to get a
four-year degree we're gonna get to
experience we're gonna get this we're
gonna get that
and uh is this a good marketing campaign
tom for b of a i think it's a populist
marketing campaign around the
simple phrase 25 dollars um however
what you're what you accurately point
out is that
there will be talent competing for those
jobs and by the way in
by 2025 you know the the number of
humans that are in
you know bank individual branches down
the street is dropping
you know there's so much all banking is
being automated so much as done online
i mean you know you you take a look at
that operation goes lower because yeah
so these are going to people and this is
going to be people in headsets and call
centers
because the corner branches i mean
they're harder and harder to find
that's actually a very good question can
we ask a question here when's the last
time you went to a branch
um last time i went to a branch it was
i i i was forced to and what i was
forced to
gun through you're at that point no no
kim and i ran back no no kim and i made
a transaction
and they had to have a bank check so i
had to go
in and get a cashier's check and then
fedex yes six months how many times have
you been in that's a better question
zero okay so zero last six months if i
didn't have to be going and get a
cashier's check because we had a large
transaction
i wouldn't have gone into about yourself
all my needs were taking money maybe
once a quarter how many how many last
six months have you been
in the branch caroline zero
not even once sam maybe once
nothing once zero kai kai we can't hear
you guy
we can't hear you kai i'm turned on go
ahead uh
get it together kai what's going on over
there buddy generally
my bank doesn't even have a branch here
so damn i don't even
have my bank don't even have branches
that's how good my bank is
okay ultimately let me ask let me ask
the audience i'm actually the first time
you see
helsinki federal you'll know that if
you're watching this
when in the last six months how many
times have you walked into a branch
out of bank i'm actually curious comment
we're watching your comments go ahead
adam go ahead
uh tom no so i think this is basically i
think this can be call centers and basic
processors in these layers
yep and 50k minimum they're not a bad
gift it's probably gonna be a job
there's gonna be a lot of people
competing for those fifty thousand
dollars your job here's what we did if
you remember just uh
uh five and a half years ago we're in
texas and
we're going through hiring people and
text minimum wage at 7 20. one day i sat
there and i said guys we're not doing
this anymore
moving forward we're hiring 15 bucks an
hour we started 15 bucks an hour and the
quality went yeah in a better direction
so
it's not you're increasing your minimum
wage for me
it's what you're saying is we are
willing to pay
more money for better employees by the
way
to the people of the minimum wage
community b of a
what b of a did to the minimum wage
community
said whether you like to increase the
minimum wage or not we don't care what
you think
we are willing to pay more for better
talent
so the market has to compete to get
these jobs
and then the market has to improve to
keep these jobs viva is not saying uh
your our minimum wage is going to be
this much now everybody's saying we're
only looking at hiring people that are
worth 50
000 or more that's what they're saying
that's correct if you are not worth 50
or more we're not hiring you that's what
they're saying but the interpretation
and the way you sell the story it's kind
of like
you know it's a 25 minimum wage america
maybe at 15 but we're going to be at 25
minimum wage great marketing but i think
b of a smart
it's going to cost them 100 million
bucks what's 100 million a few hundred
million dollars to be of a
nothing they make billions on top of
billions on interest
adam any thoughts on your end yeah i
think this is comes down to one of your
favorite words ever which is
competition so they're competing with
the chases of the world
and the wells fargo's of the world and
um and the city groups of the world
and they're basically drawing a line in
the senate and saying we're better we'll
pay more
we're looking for better talent and i
think something that it's
very important to point out minimum wage
minimum wage minimum wage talk about
this
what are the key words in this wage
obviously your pay and minimum
absolute lowest bottom of the barrel
minimum
you get the minimum pay you get the
minimum effort absolute minimum
something that i've come to recognize
since being with valuetainment for the
last year or so
is that minimum wage the whole fact that
it's a it's it's actually
it's how wait a minute yeah what did you
do i went there i went there
watch your language i'm trying i might
try my best but my gosh
soy boy on fire the fact that that 725
is an absolute minimum
yeah who the hell is taking that job
like you're either a high school kid or
you
are lucky to even be in this country or
you're just willing to accept the
absolute minimum because your skill set
is
uh less than desirable let's say so the
fact that
this is definitely something you know
you you would hear
um this is an evolution of thought
minimum wage they should be paying more
corporations should be paying more they
should pay their fair share that's not
how this comes down to the individual
if you're 40 years old and you're still
somehow making minimum wage dude what
are you doing with your life
right so this is more about the
individual recognizing totally agree
i'm better than this yep they're only
paying minimum wage i guess that's what
they're paying yeah
what kind of a loser are you right yeah
yeah i'm fired up
it's microwavable by the way yes
microwavable tea it just got me yeah
today yesterday i'm at lobster two days
ago i'm at loves with jen
we're eating out loves this guy stops by
range rover nice looking raindrop i
think his name was jeremy i think i mean
maybe it was with a jay gave me his
business card says man i love the
podcast i'm watching all the podcasts
i'm watching all your stuff love the
fact that you're in uh
uh uh uh uh what you call i'm in boca
and we're glad to have you here all this
other stuff and i said great he says um
by the way it's great also watching a
podcast with adam i said tell me why it
says because
i've watched all the episodes and i've
seen adam changed over the last 60
episodes
so people are seeing an evolution in our
buddy here
adam sosnick and we're working on adam
potentially one day running for governor
florida in the next 20 years probably
not however
good looking well-spoken sense of humor
and i don't need the accolades
behind you with the right team behind
you who knows man governor
sauce there you go with pat behind you
you can go anywhere you can do anything
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye